en este vídeo hablaremos sobre cómo
hacer un buffer o solución amortiguador
hay dos formas principales en las que
podemos hacer un buffet vamos a ver una
forma es cuando sabemos que queremos
hacer una solución buffer con un ph
específico entonces lo hacemos a
propósito para una aplicación en
particular y otro caso en el que tal vez
hacemos un buffer sobre todo en una
clase de química es por accidente por
ejemplo si están haciendo otra cosa como
una titulación resulta que muchas veces
terminaron haciendo algo que se
convirtió en una solución buffer o
amortiguadora entonces veamos estas dos
situaciones una ecuación que usaré y voy
a suponer que ya la conocen es la
ecuación de henderson hasselbeck que
th es igual a el pk y del ácido débil
más el logaritmo de la base débil que la
abreviados como a menos
entre la concentración del ácido te vi
si quieren saber un poco más sobre cómo
deducimos esta ecuación eso no lo
veremos en este vídeo pero tenemos otros
videos en donde hablamos de eso entonces
supongamos que queremos llevar a cabo
una reacción específica a un ph de 4 así
que necesitamos hacer un buffer con un
ph de 4 generalmente en este caso
hacemos una mezcla de un ácido débil más
una base débil que puede ser una base
débil como el amoniaco o quizá una sal
con la base conjugada de nuestro ha sido
débil entonces un ejemplo podría ser
ácido acético de h3c o h
ese es el ácido acético y lo podemos
combinar en una solución con acetato de
sodio n a más de h3c o menos
y también voy a dibujar las estructuras
moleculares porque creo que eso hace que
sea más fácil poder ver la relación
entre estas dos estructuras entonces
tenemos el ácido acético por aquí
tenemos un grupo ch3
y por acá tenemos un ácido carboxílicos
con un protón y es un protón ácido así
que podemos donar este protón y así nos
queda acetato de h3c o menos
y aquí tenemos un camión de sodio
entonces si combinamos nuestro acetato
de sodio en solución obtenemos un
equilibrio entre estas dos cosas y así
es como obtenemos algo que actúa como un
buffer entonces tenemos al ácido acético
que es nuestro ácido débil
y lo que hace es que lo pondré de otro
color
lo que hace el ácido débil es que
absorbe absorbe cualquier base fuerte
agregada
absorbe cualquier base fuerte que haya
sido agregada como por ejemplo iones
hidróxido entonces va a reaccionar con
los iones hidróxido para evitar que
cambie el ph drásticamente que es lo que
sucedería si el ácido débil no estuviera
presente y del otro lado de nuestro
equilibrio tenemos una base débil que es
la base conjugada del ácido débil y lo
que hace es que absorbe cualquier guión
h más agregado como por ejemplo cuando
agregamos un ácido fuerte entonces este
es un caso muy común en el que
tendríamos una solución buffer o
amortiguador a hacemos un buffer en
particular con un ph específico así que
podríamos usar la ecuación de henderson
hasselbaink y pueden decir ok yo quiero
un ph de 4 y después simplemente
buscamos las diferentes sales y supe caa
y luego ajustamos las concentraciones
para obtener
el ph que queremos pero ahora veamos el
segundo caso en el que podríamos tener
un buffer este caso también es muy común
en química y es por accidente es decir
que tal vez hicimos un buffer porque
combinamos un ácido débil con una base
fuerte o también podría ser que lo
escribiré entre paréntesis es que
combinemos una base débil con un ácido
fuerte
y esto es muy común que ocurra en las
titulaciones entonces cada vez que hagan
la titulación de un ácido débil o una
base débil al titular con una base
fuerte o un ácido fuerte terminaremos
haciendo una solución buffer y aquí
podríamos poner como ejemplo
podemos empezar nuevamente con un ácido
débil como el ácido acético que usamos
en el otro ejemplo aquí tenemos nuestro
ácido acético y esta vez lo haremos
reaccionar con una base fuerte como el
hidróxido de sodio entonces n a más o
menos que es como se disocia
y qué pasa cuando hacemos reaccionar
estas dos cosas bueno aquí ocurre una
reacción de neutralización y este protón
ácido que tenemos en el ácido acético
puede reaccionar con el hidróxido para
producir h2o y así el ácido acético se
transforma en acetato entonces podemos
ver que si hacemos reaccionar una base
fuerte con un ácido débil lo escribiré
si hacemos reaccionar un ácido débil
con una base fuerte
terminaremos con la base con jugada del
ácido débil base con jugada del ácido tb
y esto significa que aún si no
combinamos la base con jugada con el
ácido débil desde el principio como en
el ejemplo 1 lo terminaremos haciendo en
solución así que terminamos produciendo
una base aquí la clave es que podemos
ver esto en una titulación
títulación para ser más específicos lo
veremos en la región buffer
buffer y esto ocurre cuando titulamos un
ácido débil o una base débil
ha sido débil o base débil por lo tanto
no haremos una solución buffer o
amortiguador así titulamos un ácido
fuerte o una base fuerte pero si hacen
este tipo de reacciones en donde hacen
un buffer conforme ocurre la reacción
eso significa que podemos usar la
ecuación de henderson hasselbeck que
tenemos aquí para calcular el ph o las
concentraciones en la solución entonces
estas son las dos situaciones en las que
hacemos un buffer y en cualquiera de los
dos casos pueden usar la ecuación de
henderson hasselbeck para diferentes
cálculos